okay I think this is my first opponent
above 2000 try and take this a bit
seriously yeah I'm very happy for
earning one rating points huge
accomplishments gonna see how London
everyone playing the London these days
okay let's play c5 it's hard to play the
Sicilian in against the London those
guys probably watched my my video Bishop
e2 didn't Shanklin to play Bishop e2
against don't wonder the US
Championships I don't think it was this
position
maybe something slightly similar and
Bishop each I know it's a tricky line I
mean Queen b6 looks natural I could also
I could just take and Bishop f5 go to
idea Bishop e2
think about Queen b6 I would be scared
of Knight c3 Knight b5 so I don't think
I'll play Queen b6 another move is g6
Gamma the pawn just play like a reverse
Catalan yeah let's do that let's play g6
a different type of setup u6 was also
moved yeah but I like this diagonal for
the bishop my team will be safe yeah
White's just kind of sticking with a
general setup now if it takes I have 94
and I don't think I'm even losing upon
that hit B 2 and C 5 I could play this
if you like my knife belongs on g7
rather than c6 just to defend c5
EVP six here just so I don't have to
worry about it's white taking holding on
to the pond never play London against
Eric people can play London against me
it's still gonna be a fight this player
is clearly playing very solidly and this
is a hard position to crack I want to
play rook e8 Bishop e5 could be annoying
it just starts start with solid moves I
think the long-term idea for black is to
eventually play e5 but that might be
hard to do especially after this move
complain 97
yeah trying to trade off the night and
this night will come in yeah
so if rookie 895 we trade everything the
pong lands here that's probably a good
structure for black so all allow it
could you pawn saw him on the kingside I
don't know why although my block that
comment um I could but I don't want to
like weaken my king this is probably
going to be a far more positional game
in previous games I was being very
aggressive at this game yeah it's gonna
be positional so a six take sticks then
ninety five got some ops Clark Bishop
position
I think I'll allow it
you can play 95 immediately
okay now if I take with Queen I have the
bishop pair I'm just trying to find like
some small imbalance to try and hold on
to for later it's a eventually win and
have more hype
this is a major imbalance in a lot of
chess positions as two bishops versus
bishop in knights and for my experience
like stronger players do value the
bishop pair a lot more than an amateur
players but in this position like the
bishops aren't so powerful yet so it's
going to take patience my queen is AB
it's happened knowing to find a good
square for be Queen e6 it looks very
strange but it's in the center keep an
eye on the Knights you know I might
eventually play off six and someday e5
yeah the bishops are basically high
grenading until the summer time
and then they'll maybe roam free wait
never play out six always play off six
sometimes 55 bits 55 Bix bits wait
what's that song fifty such 55 or
schmitty's five so I'm sawing about 55 I
take something I take this or can I take
I take this it looks very Josh okay well
trade Queens
and
[Music]
BAM f6 looks like such an ugly move but
I'm controlling a five I want to play a
Pawnee five I want to open up the center
and enjoy life and maybe if I h5 as well
and kick the knight back to each two
yeah my most recent game against been
flying gold I played at six against him
if you watch the video with our like
both of our commentary ice played f6
inside damn and I when I played off six
he said Eric you should know better
there's something like that okay it's
not about you 6 is not you 6 would be a
major problem in buck house or crazy
house if y places a pawn or Bishop here
it's actually really troublesome
and time is levelling up night h2k let's
expand this is actually very reminiscent
of my came against Ben because the whole
idea about six was to play e5 an attack
of Bishop and eventually trapa Bishop
so question is like how do I make
progress here it still takes some work
the whites position solid there's no
like immediately clear targets I think
I'll just put the rook on c8 because
there's no open files I want to put my
rooks on the files which are most likely
to open also the files which there's
pawns being attacked so there's some
case where like I might take twice and
then play rook c2 or II to consider b5
here to winning Connect four there's
ideas of just connecting eight I want to
like play somewhat decent quality chess
but eight pawns on a row that doesn't
happen so often so he's attacking this
pawn but its defendant enough times do I
dare play g5 actually a5 makes some
sense yeah cuz there's no threats let's
play a5 Connect five BAM
is it gonna happen it's gonna be very
hard to playoff five I needed this pawn
supporting the e5 fun
I mean g5h five actually makes sense
because I'm just gaining space ideas of
eventual h4 g4
now my opponent is flustered with so
many pawns in a row again I don't think
there's any threats it's like all these
pawns are defended these pawns are hard
to attack oh but if i play this i can't
i can't play g5 quite yet
are you play h5 yeah let's play h5 oh
that's weakening to g5 though hmm I have
an idea I'm gonna play h6 idea is to
play g5 and then bring the King to g6 to
support both h5 and f5
slowly but surely yeah this pawns are
Rock Brook f1 just waiting for the doom
of Connect eight I could play g5 here
[Music]
g5 waking up seven first actually let's
play g5 peeing up sudden will come soon
also g5 hype rook t1 he's just moving
back and forth
alright now I bring the king to supports
King f1 so White's not making like full
use of time I'm moving back and forth
King coming in isn't so scary so in
order to play a five I have to double up
rooks to support this fun
yeah let's play h5 I'm so close I could
play our five necks but I don't want it
to be a blunder
yeah so I'm gonna double up rooks first
how have we not traded off any gone so
far hey love HS 100 it's g5 also this is
madness this is happiness
Rick so he's just moving back and forth
I mean this is a type of position where
like both sides have a lot of time but
the difference is that I'm making use of
my time improving improving my pieces
and also mainly my pawns 5 but then 93
he's setting up a trap very very tricky
put a 593 I've f4
okay the time has come
connect eights do I just win the game on
the spot or no game doesn't just end you
it's so beautiful
this is so thumbnail worthy I need to do
something like crazy for the thumb
wait I have to look this way and just
like whoo let's not break the mic like
being aw look at those pounds okay
we did it's not f3
okay now I have to maybe I keep pushing
pawns so it's more bits
thanks for the bits Kinect 8f for or
efore we formed the e5 square is kind of
weak so probably f4i force so nice yeah
I'm just gaining space in all areas
let's hook for hurt what are you with a
sub thanks for you and thanks for the
bits minecraft online Oh
let's take I lost upon no connect 8
survived for like I move yeah let's kill
the bishop
smort bits
Thomas Frandsen a 5 SS slam Keeks toe
with a sub and also woody thanks guys
let's play Bishop wait Bishop here pawn
takes check here still tricky you play
Bishop a6 pawn takes rook takes check
yeah let's start with Bishop here this
is a better diagonal try and exploit the
King
now become the first player to play
chess and the Kinect for game without
work if you substitute and connect four
pieces with chess pieces but then
gravity would kind of have some effect
I'm not using my DSLR I didn't charge it
fully I didn't want it to die during
stream I have to find the right cable
for for having it not die
kingi one okay
trying to be safe eighty six bits your
last bits from concordia --nz
thanks for the bits Mustique you gifting
subs okay let's stay focused time is
running low this is still possible I
could take a few times
like goog for it doesn't quite work mmm
before also it doesn't quite work
baby key not five King Kai five might be
the way to go just control more stuff
now I'll take here it's a good move its
flavor
yeah trying to connect my my pawns or at
least connected upon with the kingside
pawns
keeping some time advantage yeah this
bishop still out of play
the position is beginning to open up if
94 I just take it 92 is probably the
best move considering sacking the
exchange here I mean I could just trade
and play b4 yeah let's trade I'll play
b4 b4 makes both bishops a bit happier
opens up this bishop try saunder mind
the pawns to strengthen this Bishop that
move I forgot about can probably just
move back if 94 I take it
and now beaches hits there's no more 94
there might be back ranked mate
possibilities Brooksie won lots of avoid
trading rooks threatening be too
let's take a pond yeah this was looking
very very good let's play this move yeah
he wants to play king each one bishop do
you want free the bishop
come play work here this a - is also a
week
I'll defend with the King and push up on
okay that was a fun game Kinect eight I
don't think I've ever done that before
now I've tried to do it where it was
like it wasn't just goofing around it
was actually like these were all
reasonable moves gaining space such nice
imagery okay
I gained three rating points probably
for connecting eight plums I should get
bonus points for that unless for the
YouTube people hope you've enjoyed that
also thanks for the bits
Taji 7 life is good